don't panic that's a message from the uk
government as the country grapples with
a fuel supply crisis
after a chaotic week that saw panic
buying and fights at the pumps british
ministers say the crisis is abating but
uk petrol retailers paint a different
picture they say more than a quarter of
pumps are dry and less than half have
both petrol and diesel huge queues have
built up at the stations that have fuel
with customers waiting hours to fill up
the backlog is clogging up roads and
blocking traffic petrol retailers have
warned that until adequate supplies are
sent to stations the long queues will
continue
but those supplies can only get to the
pumps if there are enough truck drivers
to bring them britain is suffering from
a severe lack of drivers the industry
says there may be a shortage of 100 000
because of a combination of the kovy 19
pandemic and brexit it's not just a fuel
supply crisis the country is dealing
with supermarkets have seen empty
shelves pharmacy supplies have been
disrupted the pig industry says hundreds
of thousands of animals may need to be
culled because of a lack of abattoir
workers and energy supplies have gone
out of business after gas prices soared
well dw's burger mass has been to a
south london food bank to see how the
shortage is affecting some of britain's
most vulnerable
i'm at the eveline community center in
south london and twice a week here
volunteers are handing out fruit and
vegetables and bread and i'm here with
christina norman who is one of the main
volunteers and i'm just going to ask her
christina what's the impact here in the
food bank do you
feel that there is less food around we
are experiencing
less food than what we have over the
last 18 months
we're not getting
the amount of food we usually get it on
a weight and it's gone from about 440
kilos down to 200
so we are really really noticing
um
the lack of food plus the fact we've had
more people wanting to become members so
we're now putting less food across more
people
and what is it due to is that due to a
shortage of drivers who can't deliver
the food
i think it's one of the reasons is
due to a shortage of drivers where
they're just not getting the food in
um
and at the moment we've got the fuel
crisis so now
you know i mean us ourselves this week
we had to get them to deliver to us
because we didn't have fuel for our
vehicle
so i think it's all combined together
and it's it's quite important at the
moment because
benefits are due to stop soon people are
now going to have to choose between food
or fuel
and it's it's not a choice that they
should have to make
um and we're getting more and more
requests for people to become members
here and it's really really worrying
so it really does have an impact the
shortage of drivers the shortage of food
on on people's lives and in this
community yes it has a knock-on effect
if you don't have the drivers to bring
the food in you haven't got the food to
give to the community
um and the fuel so yeah everything all
rolled into one makes it a massive
massive problem for us
christina norman thank you very much and
um yeah well with this fairly bleak
picture from uh from south london where
people are
people in need and they have less food
and as christina norman just explained
um you know almost um
really not enough to to feed their
families or heat their homes
this is the situation in the uk at the
moment
you